hong kong police presented the media
with
evidence of what they say was a plot to
make and plant bombs across the city
helmets shields air guns walkie-talkies
and chemicals
and a list of targets including the
crossover tunnel
railways courtrooms and even they wanted
to lay the bomb
in the in the rubbish bin on the streets
with a field
to to maximize the damage caused to the
society
six of those arrested are secondary
school students
it is a tense time in hong kong it's
almost a week since a man
died after stabbing a police officer and
then himself
security officials classified it as a
lone wolf terrorist attack
messages on social media later offered
condolences
to the assailant's family the events of
the past few days demonstrate
that the anti-government protest
movement may not have been entirely
extinguished
and that say analysts may lead to a new
and wider campaign
against dissent it's a year since a
sweeping national security law
was imposed on hong kong now the
government is proposing legislation
to amend the privacy law a response to
the protests in 2019
when private details of police judges
and journalists
were disclosed online a practice known
as doxing
but tech companies like google twitter
and facebook
are worried the proposed changes could
lead to local employees being fined or
jailed
if they refuse to hand over data to the
hong kong government
as a consequence they've warned they
might quit the territory
one of the world's leading financial
centers hong kong's chief executive says
that only illegal behavior is being
targeted
as we all know many people in hong kong
have been traumatized by doxing on the
internet for a long time
this brought support in society to solve
this problem
so this time the amendment to the
legislation is to solve this problem
experts say the proposed changes add to
the mood of uncertainty
among foreign investors this could have
a very
negative impact on hong kong's business
climate
on its reputation and for free flow of
information
now for some the territory's reputation
for safety
is also being questioned adrian brown
al jazeera hong kong